mehr als 100.000 protestieren gegen tipp
in berlin in ganz europa waren es
millionen tätig das geplante
handelsabkommen zwischen den usa und der
eu ist in erster linie ein versuch
multinationaler konzerne die macht in
den demokratien der eu und der usa zu
übernehmen
denn das passiert faktisch tipp ist
nicht nur intransparent birgt nicht nur
die gefahr den umweltschutz um
jahrzehnte zurück zu werfen rechte
arbeit nehmen da dramatisch
einzuschränken sondern ist in erster
linie das bemühen der industrie
demokratien und ihrer bevölkerung in
geiselhaft zu nehmen bitte diskutiert
bei diesem thema intensiv mit ist es
wichtig zum ersten mal also clixoom pro
und contra
so sah es anfang oktober 2015 in berlin
aus mehr menschen als erwartet mehr als
150.000 protestierten gegen tätig was
diese menschen umtrieb war vor allem
eine informationspolitik über dieses
abkommen die keine ist niemand weiß
genau wie das abkommen aussehen wird
welche folgen das haben wird
allein das ist schon undemokratisch das
gilt übrigens auch für die abgeordneten
im bundestag die lobbyisten also die
interessen vertreten der konzerne sind
besser informiert als die demokratisch
gewählten volksvertreter allein das ist
schon ein punkt der tipp als solches
prinzipiell in frage gestellt aber es
gibt auch studien die die positiven
folgen von tip untersucht haben es gibt
also ein für und wider ein pro und
contra wobei ich zugeben muss dass ich
bei der recherche schon ein wenig partei
geworden bin
aber was ist tip eigentlich das ist eine
lange geschichte ich will sie kurz
machen
eigentlich haben die staaten der welt 19
95 jahren die welthandelsorganisation
ins leben gerufen
sie sollte den weltweiten handel
vereinfachen und das ziel verfolgen eine
weltweite freihandelszone zu errichten
also eine zone ohne zölle und
beschränkungen freier handel für alle
eigentlich ein guter plan
dabei stand im vordergrund einen
ausgleich zwischen den interessen der
einzelnen staaten zu schaffen und nicht
vorteile für unternehmen versichern doch
daran hatten industrie und handel kein
interesse niemand wollte seine
privilegien aufgeben die gespräche
verliefen im sande inzwischen gibt es
mehr als 600 vereinbarung zwischen
einzelnen staaten und
staatengemeinschaften von denen mehr als
400 in kraft getreten sind
wie soll da der handel vereinfacht
werden und jetzt wollen die beiden
wirtschaftsräume mit den momentan wohl
größten privilegien diese schützen und
auch ein solches abkommen schließen mit
tip bilden die usa und die eu den
größten wirtschaftsraum der welt tipp
heißt transatlantik trade and investment
partnership also transatlantischen
handels und investitionspartner schafft
es ist ein abkommen das die interessen
der eu und der usa gegenüber anderen
nationen wie china brasilien oder den
ländern der dritten welt schützen soll
es ist das größte handelsabkommen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts und alle
werden von den folgen betroffen sein es
wird fundamentalen einfluss auf den
verbraucherschutz den umweltschutz
das arbeitsrecht die demokratie unseren
gesamten alltag haben
damit eine freihandelszone zwischen den
usa und der eu errichtet werden kann
müssen alle möglichen standards und
regelungen harmonisiert werden das heißt
genauso in der eu wie in den usa gelten
die eu muss also regelung aus den usa
übernehmen und umgekehrt ist es zum
beispiel so dass in den usa ist er so
ist das im nachhinein nachgewiesen
werden muss dass substanzen
gesundheitsschädlich sind damit sie vom
markt genommen werden müssen
es muss also in der theorie bereits eine
schädigung stattgefunden haben
bevor sich der staat mit dem betroffenen
stoff oder produkt befasst in der eu ist
es umgekehrt es muss mit aufwendigen
untersuchungen nachgewiesen werden dass
ein stoff gesundheitlich unbedenklich
ist erst dann darf er auf dem markt so
ist in den usa zum beispiel npd erlaubt
in der eu ist der stoff der zum beispiel
möbel klebern enthalten sein kann
verboten
okay an verhandlungen also gesprächen
über solche themen ist ja erst mal
nichts auszusetzen es gibt aber zwei
punkte
die nachdenklich stimmen erstens in
verhandlungen werden kompromisse gesucht
die heißen mit sicherheit nicht höhere
standards sondern was ist der kleinste
gemeinsame nenner also was sind die
mindeststandards für beide seiten es
wird also immer über verschlechterungen
für eine der beiden seiten verhandelt es
ist also logisch zwingend dass die
situation mit tipp für beide seiten auf
zahlreichen gebieten schlechter wird
zweitens gewachsene kulturelle
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
strukturen werden in frage gestellt und
das gilt auch für beide seiten wenn die
bedingungen für alle unternehmen nachher
gleich sein sollen
dann stehen zumindest der kultur put
betrieb und seine förderung zum beispiel
die buchpreisbindung die
gesundheitsversorgung durch öffentliche
statt privater krankenhäuser oder das
deutsche reinheitsgebot beim bier zur
disposition
ob das so ist oder auch nicht wen es
trifft und der verschont bleibt niemand
weiß es das macht stutzig die
verhandlungen finden im geheimen statt
die verhandlungs dokumente sind top
secret und nur ein ausgewählter
personenkreis darf sie im so genannten
lese räumen zum beispiel in brüssel
einsehen witziges detail
die räume sind
ist ausschließlich in amerikanischen
botschaften dabei dürfen sie allerdings
keine notizen machen also wie hinterließ
darf weder stift und papier mitnehmen
die sind da verboten
wie bitte also welcher stadt ist
eigentlich 1990 untergegangen die ddr
oder die brd
das hört sich doch eher nach diktatur
als nach demokratie an wo sind wir denn
verdammt nochmal hier gut das ist schon
undemokratisch aber der ganze ansatz von
ttp bild vom prinzip her unsere
demokratie aus wie komme ich also auf
diese zugegebenermaßen steile these dass
tipp ein putschversuch multinationaler
konzerne gegen die demokratie in der eu
und den usa ist hinter tipp steht ein
abenteuerlich und demokratiefeindliche
ansatz der so unsere demokratien
aushebelt und uns als geiseln nehmen
würde
schon jetzt ist es so dass unternehmen
vor schiedsgerichten von staaten
schadensersatz für entgangene gewinne
fordern können tipp soll diese rechte
auswahl wie sieht das konkret aus
ausschließlich ausländische unternehmen
können hier klagen moment warum denn das
bitte sehr
und zweitens sind es außer staatliche
schiedsgerichte sie entziehen sich damit
komplett dem gesetzgebenden staat hier
wird einfach per vertrag eine vollkommen
neue juristische instanz geschaffen
internationale gerichte machen ja sinn
aber aufgrund eines vertrages zwischen
zwei parteien die konsequenzen wären
katastrophalen würden uns uns also
würden uns den wählern die souveränität
über unseren staat nehmen der verfassung
sind wir wir menschen die herrscher und
damit der souverän
die parlamentarier sind lediglich
volksvertreter diese souveränität würde
uns aber mit tip genommen warum ein
beispiel es rein theoretisch aber
absolut denkbar
noch kennen wir ja nicht die inhalte von
tipp also das beispiel der bundestag
beschließt den mindestlohn zahlreiche
unternehmen machen jetzt weniger gewinn
sie können die bundesrepublik
deutschland jetzt genau auf diese
entgangenen gewinne verklagen sie haben
ein recht auf schadensersatz
es könnte um millionen gehen die
bundesrepublik hätte jetzt nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder sie hebt das
gesetz auf wodurch wieder unzählige
menschen in die armut getrieben werden
oder sie geht selbst pleite
die demokratie wäre ab
schafft gut das ist erstmal rein
hypothetisch aber das prinzip stimmt
nachdenklich ein paar solcher fälle und
staat und volk wären zahlungsunfähig
oder sie würden sich dem willen der
konzerne unterwerfen müssen
arbeitsschutz umweltschutz
verbraucherschutz und so weiter sind
genau die bereiche sowieso etwas sehr
leicht realität werden können schon
heute verklagt der schwedische
stromkonzern vattenfall die
bundesrepublik deutschland auch
milliarden weil vattenfall durch den
atomausstieg in zukunft kein geld mehr
mit kernkraft verdienen kann
ich behaupte nicht dass das untergraben
der demokratie das ziel solcher
unternehmen ist sie wollen möglichst
einfach nur viel geld verdienen aber das
wären die konsequenzen vattenfall zeigt
bereits jetzt wie es geht
ich halte es für absoluten quatsch das
unternehmen schadensersatzansprüche
gegen staaten haben sollten
wer ein wirtschaftliches risiko eingeht
ein wirtschaftliches risiko ein basta
das leben ist kein ponyhof das gilt auch
für konzerne
eines kommt aber in der diskussion
bisher viel zu kurz die vorteile von
tape die wirtschaftspolitiker sagen ein
beschleunigtes wirtschaftswachstum
voraus hunderttausende arbeitsplätze
würden auf beiden seiten des atlantiks
geschaffen es gibt auch eine offizielle
studie die die eu zu den folgen von tip
in auftrag gegeben hat diese studie des
center of economic policy research kurz
zippel also cpr gibt eine recht genaue
abschätzung des zusätzlichen
wirtschaftswachstums ab es handelt sich
um 00 49 prozent mehr pro jahr was wie
bitte 0,04 9% und moment moment 0049 da
fehlen einem die worte übrigens auch die
beschäftigungseffekte sind minimal das
muss man schon sagen
in offiziellen verlautbarungen werden
gerne hunderttausende neue jobs genannt
das sind allerdings zahlen die für
jahrzehnte gelten also nicht sehr
aussagekräftig sind laut studien des ifo
instituts für das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium und die
bertelsmann stiftung sind es im
optimistischsten fall 12.000 jobs pro
jahr hier in deutschland
das ist ein anstieg der beschäftigung
von 0 03 prozentpunkten wort aber man
hätte es ja vorher wissen können after
das nordamerikanische handelsabkommen zu
mexiko kanada und den usa hat letztlich
keinen effekt gehabt ich frage mich
wirklich was der ganze aufwand soll und
warum so viele potenzielle nachteile für
ein mehr als zweifelhaftes ergebnis in
kauf genommen werden warum wir auf so
viel demokratie verzichten wollen
in köln würde man sagen was soll der
quatsch und ich frage euch was soll der
quatsch diskutiertes bitte auf n tv.de
also entweder dort könnt ihr diskutieren
und auch wurden als hier oben unterm
geht es dahin und wir können nicht nur
an den kommentaren ein meinungsbild
ablesen sondern auch ganz konkret an den
stimmen man kann dort abstimmen
vielleicht habt ihr auch andere
veröffentlichungen die vielleicht mehr
positives antibes finden
ich würde mich freuen wenn das dort
sammeln ich greife die debatte dann
wieder in einem der nächsten videos auf
und bin gespannt auf die kommentare und
eben das voting ich freue mich auf jeden
fall über eine angeregte und auch
streitbare aber vor allem respektvolle
diskussion schlag mir auch gerne themen
vor was wollt ihr diskutieren ab jetzt
hier also auf links oben auch regelmäßig
pro und contra bis dann bleib dran